it's one of the most dangerous and
mysterious places on earth it's home to
dozens of sunken ships plane crashes and
dead people it's known as the Bermuda
Triangle and it's shrouded in mystery so
what would happen if we decided to dump
our trash into it where would it go and
what mysteries would we solve by doing
this this is what if and here's what
would happen if we dumped our trash into
the Bermuda Triangle there's a 1.3
million square kilometers of ocean that
is the Bermuda Triangle goes from
Florida to Puerto Rico and then all the
way to Bermuda since the 1800s there
have been nearly 1,000 reported
incidents of people mysteriously
disappearing in the area ranging from
small bush planes carrying just two
passengers two ships 150 meters long
carrying over 300 people so if we
decided to put our trash here with that
disappear as well before we even think
of dumping our garbage into the Bermuda
Triangle we first need to figure out
exactly how we'd get there naturally
we'd take a boat as we're going to dump
our trash into the sea and a boat would
allow us to carry more and be more
accurate as to where we want it to go
now you might be thinking that this is
an incredibly risky move going right to
the center of the Bermuda Triangle
are you insane but there's a pretty good
chance that we'll be just fine there's a
number of theories some good and some
as to what really happens in the Bermuda
Triangle is it some crazy alien portal
that's abducting all our humans is there
a massive underwater city that's
underneath it or is there as scary sea
monster living in it as fun as these
theories may sound they're all
incredibly far from the truth
sorry about that one of the more
plausible theories we have about the
purview - triangle disappearances has to
do with methane explosions the theory is
that these methane explosions come up
from the ocean floor and erupt so
violently that they're able to tip even
the most massive ships but since this
theory has been proposed physicists as
well as ocean experts have debunked it
they've said there's virtually no chance
of a methane explosion being big enough
to topple over a boat and if there was a
massive explosion there's a good chance
the ship would survive that's because
boats are built to handle massive
changes in the water including huge
waves and even methane bubbles so now
that we're here with our trash we can
finally dump it but now it seems to be
just floating they're living in the
ocean where's the giant sinkhole that
makes all our trash magically disappear
you know the same place that's taken all
these planes and boats over the years
well it turns out that the Bermuda
Triangle
isn't all that dangerous sure it may be
a little mysterious but all these
disappearances can be attributed to
severe weather massive waves and human
error the Bermuda Triangle
isn't even the most lethal body of water
in the world that title can be given to
the oceans in East Asia and Australia
and although nearly 1,000 deaths in the
past 200 years might seem like a lot it
really isn't when you consider the fact
that the Bermuda Triangle is one of the
most heavily traveled areas of ocean and
sky in the world so sure we'll need to
watch out for any hurricanes and big
waves but that'll be the least of our
worries for now
we just dump tons of trash into the
ocean we thought that maybe the Bermuda
Triangle would somehow get rid of it
this was a really dumb idea
unfortunately what we just did probably
won't even be all that noticeable in the
sea an estimated 14 billion tons of
trash is thrown into the ocean every
year let's say we threw all of New
York's trash for a year into the Bermuda
Triangle
that's 14 million tons of garbage it
might sound like a lot but it would only
be a tiny fragment of the rest of the
trash that's tossed into the ocean each
year this was a pretty terrible idea and
definitely not one that should be
attempted and it's not for our safety
but for the safety of our ocean instead
of adding to the problem we should be
helping to solve it by doing our best to
clean the ocean maybe a better idea
would be to throw our trash into a
volcano that has to work right well
we'll leave that story for another
what-if
[Music]